we've been recently seeing some new
rumors about apple's upcoming iphone 13
coming with an always on display and
surprisingly
i'm actually seeing quite a few doubters
on online forums like mac rumors
so what i'm gonna do in this video is
explain why the iphone 13 pro
will for sure be getting and always on
display
so let's get started first off if we're
talking about the iphone getting an
always on display
we have to discuss the product that
apple has already given that feature
too and that's of course the apple watch
with the apple watch series 5
apple introduced the always on display
which was a feature that many people
asked for
for many many years and now the big
question is
why did it take apple that long to give
the apple watch that feature
well apple themselves gave the credit to
the low temperature
polysilicon and oxide display which
features a reinvented
pixel architecture that lets the screen
refresh rate
dip from 60 hertz to a power sipping
one hertz when the watch is inactive and
just in case you don't understand how
screen refresh rate works
let me quickly explain standard displays
like the ones on the current iphone and
macbooks
use display technology with 60hz
refresh rate and that basically means
that for every second
the image on the display updates 60
times
and that's essentially how video works
as well it's just a bunch of images or
frames
updating or changing multiple times a
second for example
most movies and videos out there
including almost all of our videos
are recorded at 24 frames per second
which correlates with 24 hertz so the
image changes
24 times every single second which gives
it a more cinematic or
film-like look however a 24hz display
would look incredibly choppy for ui
elements
so that's why apple uses the standard
60hz displays
now there are also higher refresh rate
displays like the 144 or even
240hz gaming displays but they require
a lot more power to run which isn't a
problem for
a desktop pc but it does become a
problem for gaming laptops
draining battery life much more quickly
and all of that also applies to the
apple watch
which is why apple needed to get that
ltpo display
which can go down from 60 hertz to just
one
when in the standby always on mode
saving a massive amount of battery life
which is essential for the apple watch
now the truth is that the apple watch
series 4
actually already had an lcpo display so
they technically could have given it and
always on display
if they had the other features ready
like the low power driver and the
ambient light
sensor but in my opinion apple held off
on that feature
until the series 5 because if they
didn't
then there literally would be no reason
for anyone to upgrade
to the series 5 at all since there were
barely any other changes
but basically the main point i want you
to realize
is that an ltpo display is required
to give an oled smartphone variable
refresh
rate so now let's get into the iphone
last year we actually had rumors of the
iphone 12 pro getting an ltpo panel
with 120 hertz refresh rate but reports
later came out
claiming that because of battery life
concerns apple had to choose between
either 5g
or 120 hertz and they went with 5g
since they thought it would lead to more
sales and it turns out that they were
right
because they sold 100 million iphone 12s
in just seven months
but this year we're basically now 100
sure
that the iphone 13 pro will be getting a
120 hertz display
with many different leaks and rumors
from various sources
like the supply chain and reliable
leakers
going all the way back to july of 2020
display analyst ross young let us know
that ltvo display
would not be coming to the iphone 12 pro
and he was right
then in december last year the elect
claimed that two out of four iphone 13
models
will come with ltbo displays needed to
enable 120hz refresh rate
pointing to both the pro models
exclusively
then a couple of months later max
weinbach claimed that the iphone 13
would be getting a 120 hertz
promotion display and this is actually
the first leak we have
that pointed to an always on display
feature coming
but i'll get into that in just a minute
in march ming cha quo also agreed
that the iphone 13 pro models will be
getting
120hz displays then in april digitimes
made an interesting claim
that the iphone 13 pro models will
feature 120 hertz promotion refresh rate
while at the same time using 15 to 20
percent
less power consumption and if you're
finding that hard to believe
i'll explain how it's gonna work in just
a second but going further into their
report
they said that both samsung display and
lg display
are converting their supply lines to
offer
ltpo displays at their dedicated apple
manufacturing lines
with the conversion likely complete in
the first half of 2021
and apparently just one month later the
elect reported that samsung
began production of 120 hertz ltpo
displays
for the iphone 13 pro models while lg
began production of
regular ltps displays for the lower end
iphone 13s and then just yesterday
mark german who was the most reliable
apple leaker out there
finally chimed in on this topic
mentioning that the iphone 13 will
potentially get
120 hertz and in always on mode
basically confirming that the 13 pro
will for sure
get 120 hertz no doubt about it but the
weird thing is that he mentioned that
the display will give you
better battery life so let me explain
how that's going to be possible
while also being able to go up to 120
hertz in 2017
apple revealed the 10.5 inch ipad pro
with 120 hertz pro
motion technology and the way it works
is by automatically
adjusting the refresh rate between 24
hertz and
120 hertz depending on the content that
you're viewing
so if you're on the homepage you're
getting super smooth
120 hertz but if you're watching a
youtube video filmed at 24 fps
like this one is the refresh rate goes
down to 24 hertz
and that actually saves a ton of battery
life
compared to other ipads that are always
stuck
at 60 hertz so basically the new iphone
13 pro
will come with this same tech so
watching one of our 24 fps videos
will help you save battery life which is
great
but it still won't be good enough to
enable always
on mode because of that i personally
believe that the display refresh rate
will actually be able to go down to just
one hertz
just like the apple watch and that is
what's gonna enable
and always on mode on the iphone 13 pro
models
and the reason i believe that is because
samsung's latest galaxy s21 ultra
and the new oneplus 9 pro both have
displays that can adjust between
1 and 120 hertz and oneplus
actually mentioned the scenarios when
it'll hit one hertz
and they said that whenever you look at
a static image
it goes down to one saving tons of
battery life
so basically you can expect the iphone
13 pros always on display
to work just like it does on the apple
watch with the display
dimming down and turning some of the
display elements black
while having an outline clear enough to
read things like the time
and other important info and i know that
some people were worried about display
burn-in but that is not going to be a
problem because apple has software that
can dim down individual pixels
to avoid burning and of course the
display will already be so
dim that burn-in isn't likely to happen
in the first place
so to sum up this entire video the ltpo
display technology
is the secret sauce that enables
variable refresh rate
so if apple is going to give the iphone
13 pro models
120 hertz promotion then they can very
easily give it an
always-on mode at the same time as long
as it can go down to one hertz
like the modern android smartphones
already can and i personally
think it will because of all the leaks
and rumors we've seen from max weinbach
and the very reliable mark german and if
by any chance this feature
does not come this year it's because
apple decided to hold off
just to make next year's iphone 14 pro
seem a bit better but i personally think
that we're getting it this year now if
you totally disagree with me
then go ahead and let me know down in
the comment section below but if you
enjoyed this video
definitely click the circle above to
subscribe and check out one of those two
videos right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video